antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau d'antenne de à la une ce soir
les lendemain d'un accord américano
soviétique
d'un côté l'élimination des missiles à
moyenne portée et les conséquences qui
en découlent
de l'autre une première l'urss et les
états unis acceptent des inspections
mutuelle sur leur territoire
révision à la hausse du budget des jeux
olympiques d'albertville 3,2 milliards
de francs la corse de l'état la savoie
et le comité d'organisation a été signé
ce matin
confirmation officielle de la hausse des
prix +0 2% en octobre mais attention aux
dérapages dans les services ils ont
progressé de 0 7% au cours du même mois
manifestations massives en italie les
trois grands syndicats appellent
aujourd'hui à la grève générale sur les
thèmes de l'emploi les retraites
et la récente fitial approbation conseil
des ministres de la raison du statut des
chefs d'établissements du second degré
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
veut en faire de vrais patrons une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
regardez bien cette image c'est la
première conséquence de l'accord
américano soviétique sur les oraux
missiles dont on parle beaucoup depuis
hier soir ce matin dans le désert de
l'utah l'armée américaine a procédé à un
test de destruction sur un missile
intermédiaire du type pershing de le
missile qui était dépourvu de sa charge
nucléaire a été détruit dans une fosse
de plusieurs dizaines de mètres de
profondeur la sidération a duré 9
minutes en tout et pour tout et que
l'accord sera signé entre michael
gorbatchev et ronald reagan
l'armée américaine devra détruire plus
de 100 père finn 2 je vous rappelle que
ces missiles sont implantées en
allemagne
aujourd'hui la plupart des capitales
européennes accueillent favorablement
l'accord américano soviétique
satisfaction à bonn l'on parle d'accord
historique
à paris le quai d'orsay et espère qu'au
delà de ce traité les numéro un
soviétique américain donneront une
impulsion décisive à la réduction des
armements stratégiques dans l'immédiat
vous en doutez c'est bien sûr l'accord
conclu hier qui retient toute
l'attention
un accord qui se veut très concret et
qui débouche sur une nouvelle donne en
matière de défense
gilles rabin imagera volés par des
espions américains et soviétiques en
manoeuvre ces fameux et 16 20 gagnants
leurs postes de tir
dans une clairière d'une forêt d'europe
de l'est quelque part derrière le rideau
de fer
ces missiles et 16 20 les soviétiques
voulaient détruire les 200 pages du
traité mis au point hier soir à genève
prévoit en effet l'élimination totale
avant l'an 2000 des 441 et 16 20112 ss4
et 80's s12 ss 22 et 16 23 soviétique
qui menace l'europe de l'ouest
côté américain le traité prévoit la
destruction de la totalité des missiles
implanté sur le sol de l'europe de
l'ouest
en riposte à l'arsenal soviétique les
108 pershing 2 et les 256 missiles de
croisière américains les seuls
d'armement capable de toucher à coup sûr
en cas d'invasion de l'europe le sol de
l'union soviétique
le traité prévoit d'autre part que les
centaines de contrôleurs américains
iront vérifier en urss dans les basses
soviétique la réalité du désarmement
tandis qu'autant de contrôleurs
soviétique feront de même sur les bases
européennes et américaines
une véritable révolution culturelle pour
des militaires soviétiques et américains
qui sont maladivement jaloux de leurs
moindres secrets
si le traité est appliqué comme prévu
dans trois à cinq ans ne resteront en
europe de l'est et de l'ouest que les
armes nucléaires embarqués sur des
chasseurs bombardiers les missiles
pré-stratégiques d'une portée de moins
de 500 km les armements conventionnels
ou la supériorité soviétique est
importante et la force de frappe
française
autonome et indépendante qui n'est pas
concerné par ce traité négocié entre
soviétiques et américains
une force de frappe française dont la
logique risque pourtant d'être mise en
cause très vite au nom d'une autre
logique celle de ce premier accord de
désarmement
pas de commentaire particulier à moscou
pour l'instant l'annnonce de
l'aboutissement des pourparlers de
genève et hier n'a fait l'objet que
d'une information très ponctuelle c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire
en france l'actualité politique tourne
une fois encore je ne vous surprendrai
pas au tour de la cantonale test de
marseille tout le monde aujourd'hui
commente la décision de jean marie le
pen
je vous rappelle que le leader du front
national prône l'abstention au second
tour
andré rossinot ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement demande aux
électeurs de ne pas se tromper
d'adversaire charles pasqua ministre de
l'intérieur déclare qu'il respecte la
décision de jean marie le pen
mais il souhaite que les électeurs du
front national votre pour la majorité à
gauche pas de surprise le candidat
communiste se désiste en faveur du
candidat socialiste alors dans ce
contexte très particulier de marseille
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui sont l'objet de toutes les
convoitises
à savoir les électeurs du front national
au hasard des rencontres
daniel brême a également rencontré les
deux candidats du second tour les deux
candidats qui se marquent à la semelle
se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui au même
genou droit pour leur offensive de
charme
côté socialiste andré magny v et ses
supporters ne cachent plus leur moral de
vainqueur après la consigne d'abstention
donné par jean marie le pen
robert assante candidat de la majorité
trois ans son rival s'affiche lui aussi
gagnant le moral est bon
le front national n'est pas propriétaire
de ses voix répète à l'envi rpr et udf
mais chez les lepénistes le vent est à
la mauvaise humeur
ce n'est pas de la colère madame c'est
simplement une sorte d'avertissement
avant d annexion beaucoup plus
importantes qui auront lieu dans six
mois si l'on ne veut pas de nous on aura
pas mon vote
de toute façon il faut bien qu'ils se
mettent dans l'idée monsieur léotard et
les autres que s'ils refusent les voix
du front national
ils font le jeu de la gauche que c'est
monsieur mitterrand qui passera c'est
pas évident que nous étions passés est
candidat de gauche mais j'estime que
c'est des gens n'ont pas besoin de me
vois donc ils pourront eux mêmes s'ils
sont assez forts pour passer de par
leurs propres moyens
il reste trois jours des candidats pour
mobiliser les indécis et les 60% de ceux
qui sont restés j'ai ce dimanche vernis
difficile ce soir d'établir un pronostic
le principe d'une réforme du statut des
chefs d'établissements du second degré
approuvé ce matin en conseil des
ministres rené monory parle d'une grande
réforme qui mise sur la
responsabilisation et qui débouche sur
des perspectives de carrière nouvelle
plus de 12000 personnes sont concernées
par cette réforme
tout de suite un exemple pour mieux
comprendre à confolens c'est en charente
laurine cusin on est baissière le
proviseur du lycée de confolens en
charente 650 élèves sont adultes
enseignants et non-enseignants objectifs
du proviseur animé toute cette
communauté scolaire l'a dirigé dans un
même sens
moi je le vois comme un grand patron qui
régit tout le monde oui mais il est
patron dans le sens il est assez de
liberté aux élèves et puis assez de
liberté aux professeurs si on n'a pas de
bons contacts
de l'autre côté une fois sorti de la
salle de cours avec l'administration et
ont promis les en premier lieu le
proviseur lui même le travail s'en
ressent
il ya tous membres d'un nouveau corps de
fonctionnaires investi d'une autre
responsabilité recrutés par concours
pour les nouveaux les proviseurs de
lycée et des principaux de collège ne
gagneront pas de pouvoir à l'intérieur
de l'établissement
leurs pouvoirs sont déjà importants le
but du projet de statut et surtout de
donner une nouvelle dimension aux
relations avec l'extérieur
soral avantage de nous donner peut-être
vis-à-vis de nos interlocuteurs quel
qu'il soit une une stature peut être
plus solide et donc dans les
négociations consomme d'amener à à
entreprendre dans différents domaines à
donner plus de poids aux interventions
nous pourrons faire interventions
notamment auprès des régions
propriétaire des lycées depuis la
décentralisation
bref obtenir des crédits intervention
également auprès des entreprises pour
négocier des stages pour les lycéens et
se soucier de leurs débouchés pour
l'éducation demande du pôle économique
dans l'avenir ça doit être étroitement
unis par conséquent la ya un rôle
essentiel du chef d'établissement homme
de relations publiques autant que
responsable indiscutablement le
proviseur aura une place importante dans
l'évolution des lycées l'un des grands
problèmes actuels du système éducatif
dans un autre contexte jacques chirac a
inauguré tout à l'heure en fin d'après
midi
l'école d'ingénieurs de marne-la-vallée
exceptionnellement pas de ruban bleu
blanc rouge mais à rayons laser coupé
symboliquement par le premier ministre
tout change à noter que l'établissement
de marne la vallée à la forme d'un
clavier d'ordinateur géant c'est ici que
seront formés une partie des ingénieurs
et techniciens en électronique de l'an
2000 effet est tout à fait remarquable
l'éducation sera prodigué en étroite
liaison avec l'industrie française
retour à la politique
le canard enchaîné met le doigt sur une
affaire de fausses factures qui fait
sourire
inwi titre nos confrères ce matin le rpr
demande une aide financière au canard
enchaîné apparemment ce n'est pas un gag
laurent boussier s'est penché sur le
mécanisme
voici une vraie-fausse affaire où les
démarcheurs du rpr demande de l'argent
au canard enchaîné un scénario de la vie
politique qui commence par une colossale
mépris c'est au départ une erreur
tragique du rpr qui a cru contacté une
petite entreprise d'édition parce qu'ils
ignoraient que le nom complet du canard
enchaîné c'est l'hésitation maréchal le
canard enchaîné ils ont donc téléphoné
aux éditions maréchal pour nous proposer
d'aider la campagne de jacques chirac
alors bien entendu on a sauté sur
l'aubaine on a dit certainement on veut
bien aider
jacques chirac mais on voudrait pas que
ça apparaisse
on a joué les petits end les industriels
un peu peureux frileux qui sont
sympathisants du rpr mais qui veulent
pas que leurs choix apparaît salon ne
deviez pas de problème on va vous faire
une facture dans laquelle le rpr
n'apparaîtra pas c'est la maison
d'édition qui ce qui est pas connu et
donc
j'aurai une facture en comptabilité tout
ira très bien vraie facture mais sans
prestation une pratique qui s'appelle le
cadre réservé et dont on a déjà parlé
dans d'autres affaires une pratique à
laquelle ont donc eu recours les
militants du 19e arrondissement ce soir
dans un communiqué adressé à la lfp la
20e section du rpr de paris fait part de
son indignation à la suite de la
provocation dont elle a été victime et
accuse le canard enchaîné de pratiquer
un amalgame avec les scandales du parti
socialiste politique et sondages au
quotidien après vingt mois d'activité le
gouvernement de jacques chirac présente
une image plutôt négative 52% des
français interrogés pensent que les
choses se sont plutôt moins bien passé
que prévu depuis mars et 86 30 pour cent
sont d'un avis contraire ce sondage bv à
paris match a été réalisée auprès d'un
échantillon de 928 personnes autre
sondage réalisé cette fois par ipsos 42%
des français ne font pas confiance au
président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand soit une progression
de 7 points par rapport au mois
d'octobre 45% lui font confiance en
progression de 1 point c'est tout pour
les sondages dans le val de marne à
s'amender
on s'interroge après la mort d'un
maghrébin de 32 ans l'homme abattu par
les policiers aujourd'hui serait membre
du gal commentaires d'hervé brusini
embouteillages ce matin sur le
périphérique il est 9h30 un fourgon de
police avance au ralenti l'occasion pour
l'homme qui vient d'être interpellé de
prendre la fuite un saut par dessus le
parapet
une course poursuite s'engage dans les
rues de saint mandé
j'ai vu arriver un homme qui a traversé
la rue en courant que quelques secondes
après deux policiers qui le suivaient
l'un des deux policiers s'est arrêtée
ajusté avec son arme et a tiré deux
coups de feu je vais regarder par dessus
le balcon j'ai vu l'homme étendu par
terre comme je la rue est un des
policiers qui l'a recouvert avec son
blouson est-ce que vous avez remarqué
qu'il tenait un objet une arme par
exemple à la main je n'ai rien vu est ce
qu'il vous a semblait que il menaçait
les policiers qui le poursuivaient
je le pense pas il était en train de
courir je le pense pas
l'homme a été tué sur le coup par une
balle tirée dans le dos pour faire usage
de son arme selon les règlements un
policier doit être en état de légitime
défense ce n'était pas le cas
semble-t-il ce matin le policier
auxiliaire auteur du coup de feu a été
suspendu de ses fonctions dès cet après
midi
quant à la victime selon nos
informations il s'agirait non pas de moi
mais qui remet de ahmed qui a bien connu
des services de police qui a arrêté sous
le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt délivré par
un juge de montpellier ils étaient
soupçonnés d'être membres du gal groupes
antiterroristes de libération
auteur de nombreux assassinats du
réfugiés basques en france les chiffres
du jour incertitudes et hésitations à la
bourse de paris l'indicateur de tendance
fait état d'un léger recul pas grave de
l'ordre de 0 17%
un point positif tout de même les
valeurs en hausse sont de loin les plus
nombreuses aujourd'hui à part cela le
bon indice des prix du mois d'octobre -0
2% a été confirmé cet après midi je vous
rappelle que sur un an la hausse des
prix est de 3,2 pour cent a priori le
chiffre est plutôt honorable
il n'empêche que sur un an les prix des
services ont augmenté plus de deux fois
plus vite que l'inflation
avec en prime quelques sérieux dérapages
françoise joly éric guertin enseignants
habite dans le département de seine et
marne depuis un an
il mène en quête pour une association de
consommateurs l'ufc que choisir
objet du délit le prix des services
méthodique chaque mois ils enregistrent
leur variation est la notice ali
notamment ce qui concerne la réparation
automobile après les fortes
augmentations de janvier les prix ont
continué de 21,7 tonnes nouvelle poussée
de fièvre chez les garagistes qui ont
mis au point une nouvelle stratégie
maintenant leur stratégie plus subtil il
augmente par petites petites saccades d
augmentation échelonnée dans le temps et
donc les consommateurs le
le remarque - et donc ça passe mieux en
un an le prix de la réparation
automobile a progressé d'environ 12%
près de quatre fois plus que l'inflation
les professionnels se défendent ils ont
besoin d'investir distille pour faire
face à l'évolution technologique des
véhicules
nous avons un impératif besoin de nous
équiper en matériel et en personnel et
d'assurer une formation beaucoup plus
grande pour notre personnel
les arguments difficilement utilisable
pour les sociétés de parking 9% de
hausse en général avec des cases extrême
dans ce parking du xviie arrondissement
de paris près de 60 % d'augmentation en
un an
je prends ma dernière facture par
exemple du mois de novembre 87 je viens
de recevoir l'état 1200 francs un pour
cette place deux parties or il ya un an
novembre 86 elle était à 760 francs chez
les coiffeurs aussi il y a de quoi faire
la grimace
si certains cheveux se dressent sur la
tête les dernières coupes à la mode ne
sont pas seuls en cause
la profession en effet augmenté ses prix
de 8 à 11% par rapport à l'an dernier
même punition même tahri dans les
blanchisseries dans les cafés ou dans
les hôtels jusqu'au prix des ramonage
qui se sont enflammées cet automne une
évolution du prix des services qui
inquiète le gouvernement
au risque de compromettre l'appelation
et qu'est-ce que ça entre elles
s'entraînent la remise en cause les
salaires donc l'équilibré des finances
publiques dont je crois que les
professionnels doivent se ressaisir
impérativement et s'il ne le faisait pas
d'ailleurs je crains fort que le marché
les sanctionnerons
enfin au hit-parade de ces augmentations
le prix de certains spectacles va % de
hausse en un an
bref il ya délit pris ton tu n'aimes pas
libye oui mea culpa un l'inflation en
octobre est l hôtel de + 0 2 et non
moins 0,2 j'espère que vous aviez tous
qu'aux riches
chaque héros général et en français dans
le texte grève générale l'italie est
paralysée depuis ce matin par une grève
qui devrait faire date
c'est la première fois en effet depuis
plusieurs années que l'unité syndicale
refait surface en italie en point de
mire la politique économique du
gouvernement gorria aujourd'hui dans les
meetings et dans les manifs elles
étaient nombreuses
il était hier question du nouveau
miracle économique italien un miracle
qui a fait de la péninsule la cinquième
puissance mondiale en italie commentaire
de marcel trillât cela ne s'était pas
vue en italie depuis plus de sept ans
les trois grandes confédérations
syndicales la cgi elle socialo
communiste lui yale socialiste et la cis
elle chrétienne appelaient à la grève
20 millions de salariés une cinquantaine
de villes en été comme ici au centre de
naples paralysée par d'imposantes
manifestations principaux mots d'ordre
l'emploi les retraites l'aide aux
régions du sud déshérité et surtout les
allégements fiscaux pour les salariés
promis par le gouvernement puis retirée
de la loi des finances après la crise
boursière à rome plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de manifestants ont envahi les
rues du centre-ville à milan quatre
défilés ont rassemblé 50 à 70 me de
manifestants les cortèges spectaculaire
pour une valve général dans le succès
est plus difficile à mesure dans les
transports la paralysie est presque
total les grands magasins en revanche
sont restés ouverts et le succès de la
grève dans les grandes entreprises est
mitigé 13 à 24 % par exemple à la fiat
de turin la paix la direction 30 %
d'après les syndicats depuis quelques
temps les salariés italiens semblaient
de plus en plus sensibles au mot d'ordre
des cas
bath les comités de base qui reprochent
aux syndicats traditionnels leur
mollesse à l'égard du patronat et du
gouvernement les grandes confédérations
ont voulu démontrer aujourd'hui qu elle
seule représente est réellement la base
objectif atteint en partie seulement
en france la colère des mineurs très tôt
ce matin des manifestants venus de
forbach compte envahir lagarde stirling
wendel en moselle
ils entendaient ainsi protester contre
la politique de démantèlement des
houillères du bassin lorrain
d'importants dégâts vous le voyez ont
été commis avec pascal vanier voyons les
autres télégramme de l'actualité ensuite
place au sport avec jean ma mère en
direct sur le plateau
situation toujours délicate dans les
prisons américaines à atlanta les
réfugiés cubains détiendrait encore près
de 100 otage des détenus se seraient
rendus vendredi les états unis avaient
demandé 2500 extradition pu annoncer un
moratoire face aux événements
aujourd'hui le geste de cuba promesse d'
amnistie pour les prisonniers de retour
c'est la saisie d'armes opéré ces
derniers jours en tunisie les armes pour
assassiner des personnalités de l'état
les révélations du ministre de
l'intérieur il n'a pas prononcé le nom
de l'ex président bourguiba pas
d'accusations précises non plus 73
personnes sont arrêtées
y figurent des militaires et des
policiers li peng successeur de the
giang le nouveau premier ministre sera
confirmé dans ses fonctions en mars
le point final au remaniement politique
en chine les réformes de l'ip est ils
seront d'abord économique sur le plan
politique la démocratisation et pour
plus tard il faut d'abord la préparer
retrouvée blessée dans sa voiture près
de beyrouth richard jean paul est décédé
atteint de trois balles dans la tête
ingénieurs français était dans le coma
depuis douze jours le mystère demeure
sur ses agresseurs et leur mobile
l'ambassade de france projette toujours
un acte anti français mini-événement ce
matin dans les ateliers de l'arsenal de
brest où l'on vient de soudés au laser
la précision est importante la première
tôle du porte avions à propulsion
nucléaire charles de gaulle ce bâtiment
de 36 mille tonnes dont vous allez
découvrir dans quelques instants la
maquette réalisée au 1 400 millièmes
aura une longueur de 260 m la
construction du charles de gaulle menée
par la délégation générale pour
l'armement donnera 14 millions d'heures
de travail aux arsenaux de brest
le coût total de sa fabrication est
estimé à près de 14 milliards de francs
sans compter les avions qui seront
embarqués les essais la mère de ce
nouveau porte avions que voici devrait
débuter en 1995
rassurez-vous ce n'était qu'une maquette
l'automobile cocorico c'est une voiture
française qui vient d'être élue voiture
de l'année 1988
la peugeot 405 que voilà s'impose haut
la main devant la citroën ax 252 et la
honda prélude toutes les autres voitures
placées sont japonaises ce sont les
confrères 17 pays européens qui ont voté
on attend maintenant des
tombé commercial côté compétition c'est
la lan chile prions gens ma mère est oui
erland fiat qui a réussi le doublé cette
année le tilly le titre des
constructeurs cela on le savait déjà
mais qui depuis cet après midi vient de
remporter le titre des pilotes avait qu
à cancun
vainqueur du rac rallye automobile club
et qui empoche par la même son deuxième
titre de champion du monde mais rien n'a
pu arrêter la marche en avant de juha
kankunnen aujourd'hui pas même la neige
son duel avec la laine n'a duré que
l'espace de six épreuves spéciales
en tête pratiquement depuis le départ
quand tu n'aimes devance l'audi quattro
de pire et clowns de trois minutes 12 et
la ford sierra de 12 kwh est de 3,40
un très bel exploit de caen cubaine
réaliser dans les conditions
météorologiques particulièrement
difficiles et sur des chemins
particulièrement chaotique à la barre
ils me font prendre des chemins
impossible si l'année séjour rallye du
monde c'est pas nous donner ya rien là
bas à part cela on pense déjà aux jeux
olympiques de 92 à albertville en france
à quatre ans de l'échéance l'état fait
un geste en espèces sonnantes et
trébuchantes
et oui car la dernière crise monétaire
semble avoir une influence sur le budget
prévisionnel des jeux olympiques alors
chute du dollar qui influencent et
surtout ce que l'on appelle les futures
recettes commerciales du genre droits de
télévision aux ventes des produits
alors disons que pour compenser ce
manque de devises à venir eh bien l'état
a fait un gros effort les détails de
francis maroteaux suite logique de ce 17
octobre 1986 la signature de jacques
chirac pour le gouvernement de michel
barnier président du comité
d'organisation et de nelson paillou
président du comité olympique français
mais entre octobre 86 et la signature de
cet après midi beaucoup d'événements
notamment le dollar qui chute de 8 à 6
francs et et droits télévisés qui ne
représente plus que 54 % du budget au
lieu de 67 % montre a gagné environ 300
millions alors l'état prête qui sous
certaines conditions et de tenir les
prix donc de gérer ce budget avec
vigilance avec rigueur ensuite elle est
de réaliser des équipements utiles à la
région en évitant
qu'ils soient somptueux il faut qu'ils
soient aux normes du seuil haut à la
hauteur de ce que sont les jeux
olympiques mais également nous avons à
penser à l'après jeux olympiques donc
pour les routes pour les hôpitaux pour
les réseaux d'eau et d'assainissement
pour les équipements sportifs
notre souci est de prévoir ces
équipements aujourd'hui et puis tu mens
de la région de justifiant
l'augmentation du budget à 3 milliards
176 millions autrement dit 243 millions
d'augmentation en fait la manne
supplémentaire de l'état
193 millions remboursable en deux mots
voici les traditionnels pronostiquent de
pierrette brès pour le quarté et le
tiercé de demain c'est sur l'hippodrome
de vincennes dans le prix de valence et
il ya vingt partants voici les chevaux
les préférés de pyrèthre le vin pain
chester le neuf petites perrine le 13
prince de beslon le 7 petits safir le 8
olga debout près le 19 aux filles au
gloss c'est ça hein
le 18 olga de rivière le sisp achats des
charmes
voilà j'aurai que je récapitule le vin
le neuf le 13 le 7 le 8 le 19 le 18 et
le 6 espérons qu'il n'y aura pas de
neige demain sur l'hippodrome de
vincennes est pas évident c'est pas prêt
encore non je pense pas qu'il neigera
mais il a neigé serré en ile de france
aujourd'hui et vous avez raison de
souligner alors il a neigé aussi un peu
partout en france tous ayant des images
là qui nous sont parvenues des quatre
coins de l'hexagone si je puis dire
je me permets de cette expression avec
dans le massif central là c'est moins
drôle
vingt mille foyers sont privés
d'électricité à la suite de ruptures de
câbles haute tension
ces câbles surchargé par des manchons de
neige glacée
il faut dire qu'elle est tombé 20 cents
à 50 cm de neige
et là vous voyez à saint étienne vallée
française un petit village de lozère
vous voyez le facteur pour jour à l'âme
voilà le facteur qui amène grâce à un 4
4 1 espèce de voitures 4 4 il amène donc
le courrier alors tout de suite nous
enchaînons sur la photo satellite mon
dieu que ça va vite vous voyez les
nuages qui tourne si rapidement zaur
volontairement accélérée cette image
pour vous montrer que nous sommes pris
dans une toupie nuageuse voilà notre
titre qui apparaît nous avons un
anticyclone sur l'atlantique
un anticyclone sur l'europe de l'est et
au milieu une dépression qui tournait
quittons et elle va tourner jusqu'à
dimanche c'est pourquoi je pense que
nous verrons ce temps le même temps
jusqu'à dimanche avec deux mains un peu
moins de neige un peu moins de pluie et
sur la façade a plein la façade de l'est
du pays voyez encore des chutes
neigeuses sur tous les massifs
montagneux
également sur le massif central ils ont
quand même de belles éclaircies sur le
languedoc-roussillon et les exercices
sur la bretagne qu'est ce que j'écris
mal et puis des averses orageuses sur la
côte d'azur et la corse est température
ne bouge pas par rapport à celle
d'aujourd'hui des températures très
fraîches et nous garderons demain par
exemple du côté de tours en touraine
exactement à avoine 6 degrés 6° avoine
où il est tombé quelques flocons
aujourd'hui les premiers flocons
d'avoine bien sûr et demain nous
fêterons les delphine alors que le
soleil se lèvera à 8h17 pour se coucher
à 16h50 mais jerry lewis était à paris
aujourd'hui devant la presse il a
confirmé qu'il parrainerait et qu'il
conte présenterait et le téléthon des 4
et 5 décembre prochains sur antenne 2 le
téléthon pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient
encore est une grande opération pour
lutter contre la myopathie et ceux qui
en souffrent
jean jacques dufour derrière le nez
rouge de clown un coeur gros comme ça
depuis des années que jerry lutte contre
la myopathie et cet après midi il
donnait une conférence de presse pour
expliquer toute l'importance du téléthon
d'antenne 2 qui les 4 et 5 décembre
devrait permettre de récolter des fonds
pour aider les chercheurs à vaincre
cette terrible maladie qui touche 15
mille enfants en france la myopathie est
une maladie qui frappe les enfants
la myopathie du muscle après muscle
petit à petit les enfants décline et
pourtant il se bat aujourd'hui recherché
en plus qu'à me soit une piste faut leur
guérison
la myopathie maintenant c'est une
question d'argent aux états unis cette
année son 38e téléthon a été suivi par
120 millions de téléspectateurs et a
permis de récolter 40 millions de
dollars 24 milliards de centimes devront
des scans les magic décembre
on peut faire de la magie le 4 et le 5
détendent l ue je suis sûr en voyant les
visages souriants des enfants myopathes
vous aurez tous envie de les aider
les 4 et 5 décembre pendant vingt-huit
heures de télé non stop
jerry le pitre mettra tout son talent en
compagnie des vedettes d'antenne 2 au
service d'une cause qu'il défend depuis
38 ans vaincre la myopathie
selon lui les chercheurs français sont
parmi les meilleurs il faut les aider
car ils peuvent gagner cette bataille
les 4 et 5 décembre prochains jerry
lewis co présentera donc le téléthon en
compagnie de gérard holtz michel drucker
et claude sérillon ce soir sur antenne 2
c'est jean marie cavada qui présente la
marche du siècle thème de ce soir la
femme de 40 ans plusieurs générations de
femmes seront présentes sur le plateau
jean marie cavada accueillera notamment
françois giroux edith cresson françoise
de panafieu et charlotte rampling qui
sera avec nous en direct la marche du
siècle c'est ce soir peu après 20h30 sur
antenne 2 derniers rendez vous vers
23h30 avec une autre femme aux couleurs
d'antenne 2 aubry et de l'air n'oubliez
pas demain matin
télématin à partir de 6h45 à 7h45 7
harlem désir le président de sos racisme
qui sera l'invité des 4 vérités présenté
par notre ami morin très excellente
soirée sur l'a2 merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve demain 20h bonsoir